Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Connors again episode six of my journey through cancer.
Today I'm going to be talking about the Budwig protocol and the Budwig diet.
It's not something I've been doing very long at all. In fact, in full disclosure,
I just started it just this weekend. So something I'm familiar with a lot. Nothing we really ever
pushed in our practice. We have numerous dozens and dozens of patients that were already doing it,
and I found no problem and continued doing it and never asked anybody to stop doing it.
But I haven't had personal experience with it. I thought I'd better get my feet wet
in this. So I started that this weekend and it tastes delicious, especially since I've been off
dairy for over a year now. There is dairy in the Budwig protocol. The first thing that everybody
asked me is that if I'm not supposed to be eating dairy, should I be doing the Budwig protocol because
you are doing cottage cheese with the Budwig protocol? And my answer is yes, I believe you can because
when you are using your immersion blender with the cottage cheese and the the flaxseed oil, you are
emulsifying the fat in there. Now you're still getting IGF1 in the dairy. So if you test it out with IGF1,
you know, personally ask me about this because I may not have told you that. When we test people,
we test if they react to IGF1. Those are people that we highly recommend the fasting mimicking diet too.
That maybe Budwig protocol isn't something you want to do. So if you're a patient of my
publicity to this, if you're not doing the Budwig protocol that I would suggest, maybe you stay
continuing to not do the public Budwig protocol. If you are doing it, I've already given you the
AOK on it, then you could continue to do it. Now you are using cottage cheese, you're using
good cold press flaxseed oil. A little bit about Joanne, about Budwig. She was a brilliant researcher
of fats, saturated fats, hydrogenated fats. She was the first person she lived, was born and raised
and lived in Germany. And she was the first person to raise the red flag against trans fats,
causing cancer and disease. She was a researcher. So you don't hear a lot about her. Her
information was taken and used by other institutions. But she was quite a brilliant person. She believed
that she found a major piece of the cure for cancer by proper use of fats so that the cells could
get the fat that they needed and will help oxygenate the cells. And she believed this protocol was very
beneficial. It's just another protocol. I think it's a piece of your big protocol and that's how
I've always looked at it. Now what it's using is cottage cheese and flaxseed oil and flaxseeds.
So you end up not going to describe it. I'm going to point you with the next slide to a video that
can describe it. Literally it's so simple. You use two parts cottage cheese to one part flaxseed
and then for every part of flaxseed oil I mean. For every part of flaxseed oil you're using grown
flaxseeds and you have to grind them fresh. So you're going to need a few pieces of equipment for this.
You're going to need a coffee grinder and you're going to need an immersion blender. So a coffee grinder
and an immersion blender. When you take the flaxseed oil and you mix it with double the content of cottage
cheese and you use an immersion blender it's going to look like this. It's actually going to look
broader than this. I stole this picture off the internet. I should have taken a picture of my product
this weekend so if you haven't done it so you know what it looked like. This is cottage cheese
maybe blended up but you have to add the flaxseed oil so it'll look a little tannish golden
look to it and then you grind the flaxseeds and you add the flaxseeds to this and then you mix it
up together and you are allowed to put some fruit. I use some raspberries in mind. Tasted like
maybe cottage cheese pudding. So I used to love cottage cheese but I think part of it was I liked
the texture of cottage cheese. Well you lose the texture because you're blending it up with the
immersion blender and I suppose you might not like the taste. Some people don't like the taste
to this so that's why they add the fruit because of the flaxseed oil. Now I don't buy the taste but of
course with my nasal polyps I can taste anything so I think it tastes great. So that's going to have to
be something that you're going to have to experiment with. A video that I would highly recommend is
this YouTube video right here. This is a gal who heard her husband had a little baby who had
cancer and they've been dealing with this little baby with cancer. Their website is www.steredstgrn
method.com. I think that's what it is. You'll find it on her YouTube video. This is just a six minute
video. She does a great job. You'll see the little baby little guy comes up here to eat the
budwig mixture afterwards and just loves it. This is an immersion blender. This is a coffee grider.
You're using flaxseed oil and cottage cheese and fresh flax seeds. You have to blend them and
grind them right there because ground up flax seeds really go rancid quite quickly. So you have to
have whole flaxseeds. You grind them and you mix it together. Literally it takes two minutes to
do this protocol and these are super easy to clean and this is easy to clean. So it's really a simple
thing to add and a simple thing to do and it could have great benefits. So go to this YouTube channel
right here. I'm not going to try it. I thought well maybe I'll make my own video but why not? We'll
just give them credit. These are great people. They use a ripe machine. They use a whole bunch of
different things for their little guy and he's had great results. So great testimonies there too.
So all right hopefully that helps. Thanks so much.